us schauspieler bill berry ist bekannt
für seine komischen auftritte und seinen
schlagfertigen witz das beweist auch
sein auftritt auf dem roten teppich zur
welt premiere seines neuesten films isle
of dogs bei der berlinale doch der
67-jährige kann auch anders dieses jahr
überschattet dimitri debatte über
sexuelle diskriminierung und belästigung
von frauen in der filmbranche viele
festivals ebenso in berlin und in diesen
zeiten zeigt auch mary zur abwechslung
mal seine ernste und verständnisvolle
seite es ist nicht nur so im
showbusiness schon wenn man durch die
straßen in new york läuft kann man sehen
wie einige männer auf frauen zugehen und
sie mit ihren augen verschlingen wie als
frau wird man ständig gemustert immer
ich glaube nicht dass das gefallen würde
als frau würde ich wahrscheinlich viel
zeit in meinem eigenen vier wänden bei
der eröffnungsgala der berlinale
forderte kulturstaatsministerin monika
grütters einen kulturwandel in der
filmbranche
die me to debatte war durch den skandal
um die missbrauchsvorwürfe gegen
hollywood-produzent harvey weinstein
losgetreten worden
spätestens mit dem vergewaltigungs
vorwürfen mehrerer schauspielerinnen
gegen regisseur dieter wedel erreichte
die debatte auch die deutsche kultur
industrie